hello everybody my name is markiplier
and welcome replay when we do that okay
open the door I'm gonna go down to the
UM the compound down south and see if I
can get something come on thanks honey
mmm wait so should I come with you or no
what do you want to come with me I mean
I could I've got a hunting thing and
stuff okay hopefully we cuz I've
actually found low quality metal or
metal scraps when I was there so
hopefully we can find something and then
we do we can make a gun and I found ammo
I was there before - yeah let's do this
it's like directly to the south here so
we're not that far away from it but it's
like we got to go in and get out real
quick cuz man that radiations up [ __ ]
oh yeah we really outfit it now like our
hunting bows out you know that's okay I
need clothes we're too badass fourth oh
wow that's right here yeah I know I
didn't even notice it cuz it was friggin
so and to get home we just go straight
back towards the big mountain in the
distance yeah yeah like actually like
straight out the gate because it's like
directly towards our home so there's
potential there might be other people
here possibly but over with this little
population right now anyway hopefully
well yeah it we were unlike an almost
empty server before we got shot in the
face okay when we get in there I'll go
right you go left
I'm going up this building we get like
get up to I think it starts hurting at
400 grads so get out of there before you
have 400 empty building killing me
flashlight I got a flashlight nice no
there was technology in this world well
I I read in the controls that F operates
your flashlight so I assume whew laser
sight these are all fantastic if I had a
gun oh man I wish I could take this what
it's like a floaty barrel thing
it's like for cooking here oh maybe we
need one of those how do we get that I
don't know I wish I was finding anything
I haven't found a single thing yet it's
like this place has already cleaned out
I got a few things but I didn't get a
chance I'm getting out of here I'm
getting some stuff but nothing good no
metal scraps yeah I'm only up to 128 now
what are you at 255 okay it must be
heavier over there yeah you get out of
here go back home
what's that is that a person or a zombie
zombie I'm gonna go up in the building
here like in this big building Oh what
what did you die
I got headshot know your stuff I'm gonna
get blown away then aren't well no I got
oh you like clawed me in the face that I
instantly died why didn't you use your
bow I I don't know you know dumb were
you already damaged oh we've got sulphur
and we've got 104 metal fragments in our
furnace I found I actually found I mean
I found rad Stu boots I'm making a gun
make a gun how do i what do I need for
that actually I don't ice them I don't
know you you actually only need five I
need low quality metal how the balls do
I make that no can you craft it from
here in metal fragments faulty metal I
only need 15 gosh
god I killed that zombie it had a
blueprint for a hollow site PP I don't
know what that is but it sounds awesome
I have I have enough to make enough low
quality metal to make a 9-millimeter
pistol
we need ammo too though we need I have
ammo actually I have a lot of
9-millimeter am I really yes do you want
your hand rock do you want me to get
your hand rock back all we need to make
a workbench to make that I'll get both
of your hand rocks back I know you're
busy but I'm gonna get them yeah do that
do you got it I want I like the hand
rocks my god I'm gonna make a workbench
and then oh my god we suck what do we
have stone
oh stop I will get stones on the way I
need stones to make a workbench to make
a gun I'll get stones for you meet stone
calm down I'm getting stoned need stone
deposit I'll be back in just a bit
III don't need a lot it's it's how much
five I got four is that good enough
weird number all right I'm getting more
there's another stone deposit over here
did you get all my stuff back yeah yeah
I got your stuff even your hand rocks
also we have 17 more cooked chicken
really I am the best provider ever you
uh wait no I was a provider you're the
homemaker I'm the best home provider
ever
we're not sponsored by anyone any
company no one would sponsor us we asked
no one wanted to [ __ ] no one wanted in
on this no I mean come on look look at
this I mean who wouldn't want to be in
on this right right right right you guys
would want to be in on this I'm I'm sure
they would yeah I have six stones do you
have any stones at all no in any of the
boxes no all right there's a boulder
right behind it so hopefully I'll get to
see your head popping out from behind
the door just like hmm completely
horizontal as you were leaned over the
thing okay wasn't that funny to you but
it was fine no really
oh wait would I need some of you I got
some wood I just need enough to make
ball come on I only got one oh no I got
enough stone I got nine stone now baby
all right
yeah buddy where you go I'm right by now
boo stone don't stones in the fire fire
stone Oh
not sponsored by Firestone damn it I
know we keep trying but it just it don't
work do we need more war you have wood I
have wood yes I need 30 wood apparently
I'll give you the rest of it I'm gonna
put how do I put this stuff in the
furnace it's it's already going sorry oh
okay so
oh so you can't use it yeah it has to
fully cycle that's why this fire in here
inside the inside the place I put like
eighty would and like forty chicken in
it so when that's done we just have like
an infinite supply of food but it's been
going for freaking ever so yeah I've
been I what I've been guessing that it's
like a one to one ratio of wood to to
cooking stuff yeah so I put like 10/10
wood and ten chicken in this outside
fire and I'm gonna see how long that
takes
okay cool but in the furnace right now
I've got about twenty wood and I've got
a bunch of metal and sulfur so you know
what's totally badass
I have anti-radiation Wow that's the
workbench man I was looking over there
box now I can make a 9-millimeter pistol
now I can make low quality metal yeah
which I can with which I can make a
pistol yeah and I know a lot of you guys
are asking they're like well if he's
right there
why didn't I record his fraps and put it
in with mine to be honest I could have
done that at any moment I could have
done that I didn't because I'm lazy and
I didn't feel like cutting in one over
the other and say I was just too much
work I didn't feel like it I am at fault
they're marking what it's crafting do
you have 9-millimeter ammo yes I do lots
of it actually really yeah I found a lot
of ammo can i oh you want some ammo oh
crap I left the friggin workbench I have
to stand by the workbench to craft this
oh well that makes sense being up to
close the door while we're in here man
this is one frame place yeah I'm glad
all this random crap fits in here I hope
this doesn't mess with our spawns I'm
sure it's fine what did you need ammo
ammo 9-millimeter am i right I'll give
you half a mine you make me another gun
we'll look I only have enough for one
gun right now but when that's done
smelting in the furnace okay let me out
I'm gonna go hunt some wood okay there
we go
I'm gonna hunt it down and kill it dead
I done good I'm just gonna kill some of
these watch me not
oh what a shot all right up yes because
I'm not saying a prayer for the sport
deers being a little menacing there eh
Bob oh no one saw me miss don't need my
hand rock anymore oh you can you can
ironsights help you aim unlike those
[ __ ] who killed us before they
couldn't name or the damn bow with this
laser sight you'll be yes if I kill this
deer kill that deer oh that was very
loud know that we have guns did you at
least close the door before you love I
forget did I or didn't I oh you did good
job you did good good I'm actually gonna
make another shelter so that we can get
another storage thing going cuz I have
two large wood storage things are you
are you at the house right now yeah I'm
almost there all right I have four slots
on this pistol I don't know what that
means
oh you can you can upgrade look at dump
looted dumbass over there hey one of us
has a gun and one of us does that laser
sight at oh hang on this is a stick-up
wave your arms around
we have guns now let's celebrate in our
tribal dance oh I got weird I'm gonna
see if I can like I stuck it on the gun
can you see my laser sight oh I'm gonna
laser sight this bore in the face you
know it's better about playing with you
than wait
you get way more excited about the
simple things and I like that I like
that oh it's charging you perfect
no I didn't kill him at all that's it's
way more effective I guess I should stop
using all of our precious ammo for
pointless things I should I could
probably make some more I'm gonna put
this away before I lose it do that and
someone comes by because I know that
people heard that we have a lot of cloth
I'm gonna make yeah I guess I'm gonna
make no that's not worth it these rad
boots are real good man
do you see the rad boots on my feet ease
yeah they're like greenish put all of
our metal fragments I guess in the box
oh wait I was I was making another was
making another thingy I need to make
another door what is what is blood for I
think it's med kits I really do I need
what do I need for AMRO oh the furnace
is done oh I need metal dragon for ammo
there's a there's a hundred and one
metal fragments in the furnace cord God
okay you make me a gun give me someone
to make ammo well okay well I'm gonna
use up almost all of this to make you a
gun oh really it takes that much it's uh
let me look here on here's more metal
or like yes you put it in there with
I've got some wood if you need some how
much I was I was doing one-to-one and
all the woods gone so okay so I'm gonna
put do I take all that stuff out of
there what does this tell fur do the
sulfur well the sulfur the yellow one is
is refined the sulfur or refines into
sulfur I think we can use that for
others though okay I'm taking the sulfur
or out of there I'm gonna put that in
there I only have 19 woods so yeah I'm
gonna use almost all of your metal
fragments to make the gun like I'll have
26 left is that enough for anything well
then yeah only one let me finish this
crafting and then I'll give you the rest
of the metal fragments okay open the
door I need to go get some wood thank
you are all these trees depleted I died
there's a wood pile yeah what's on the
left behind us I got it okay I'm gonna
put the metal just did you oh you're
getting wood for the furnace Oh any type
of these games congratulations everyone
we worked really hard on this view thank
you so much for being here with us
mine mine are always fun I know you're
that that's cuz you're always funny Bob
and I'm nod can I can I come in yeah I'm
making your gun right now and here's
your metal fragments alright and this is
the tightest tightest cram possible
little space oh my gosh the fires done
we still don't know it only made nine
chicken dammit
but it made 105 charcoal I guess I
didn't put as many chicken in as I
thought I did okay okay we still have
like with 28 cooked chicken breasts
alright apparently don't expire so
that's good did you ever get my stuff
when I died can I have my hatchet back
this didn't do [ __ ] I thought I was
gonna make lip batches of four oh we
need a lot more ammo but we can scavenge
ammo better than we can craft it either
way here's half of it
it's 22 more bullets
you yeah I'm like where'd they go
Thunder land oh it's still crafting the
gun there's a gun in the storage box you
can just take that one oh wait there's
not a gun in the storage box with my
head I I put my gun in the storage box
and then I took it out here here's your
gun stick with a frickin bow oh never
mind I like the gun but can I have my
hatchet in my bow and stuff yeah here's
the hatchet here's your bow here's some
arrows I had I had a lot of arrows I may
have I used some okay I apologize
sincerely I'm not really sorry
you're a jerk I know I know I like that
I can whisper now and the quality sound
setup we got going on here we actually I
bought this equipment while you're alive
screams it's actually not bad for
in-house recording - hopefully I got a
plane yeah let's check out check out
where it is check out where it is it's
right here man did drop anything maybe
it already dropped it I didn't see well
that doesn't seem so excited man I was
excited oh well all right we are
actually all out of time for this
episode - ah the team is really far
pistol is really well crafted five
pieces of metal is a whole minute oh oh
I'm sorry I did not know the art
disrespecting my craftsmen right let's
get in the house go inside close the
door all right so this is like beyond we
hide in our tiny house I still don't
know not know if the spawns are gonna be
messed up with our beds like that yeah I
hope not because if we have to come back
here from so far no we'd never find it
but either way this is a lot of fun like
seriously this game is pretty pleased
with a friend it is super duper if you
can find your friend yeah if that's
possible yeah if you're awesome our
strategy was we probably started to look
to the mountain head to the mountain
remember the ridges so you know which
side of any one just use that as your
landmark so anyway this will be the last
episode recording in this batch so thank
you all so much for watching and as
always we will see